en las próximas horas se seguirán
conociendo los resultados en Nevada y en
Arizona pero ya conocemos que hace
precisamente unos minutos se proyecta ya
ganador para la sigue al senado en
Wisconsin será Johnson que será
reelegido en Johnson fue apoyado por
Donald Trump lo que está pendiente es
precisamente la Silla en Georgia que
Rafael warnord y
disputan y ya se pronostica también que
irán a un desempate ese desempate será
el 6 de diciembre dado que ninguno de
estos dos candidatos logró más de 50% en
la votación en Georgia precisamente se
definirá según los analistas la mayoría
en el senado Así que estamos muy
pendientes porque los próximos días de
aquí al viernes dicen analistas se
conocerá al menos la mayoría en la
cámara de representantes mientras
avanzan estos resultados quienes
podríamos decir que son los grandes
ganadores y Los grandes perdedores de
esta jornada electoral
por el lado republicano sin duda uno de
los grandes perdedores es el presidente
el ex presidente Donald Trump quien la
próxima semana dijo que anunciará su
candidatura la presidencia del 2024
Trump apoyó a muchos candidatos que
perdieron sus escaños entre ellos él la
candidato a la gobernación de
Pensilvania y también el médico para
ocupar la Silla republicana de El senado
de Pensilvania que ganó John peter mann
y el ganador por el partido republicano
sin duda es rondant gana la Florida por
con grandes márgenes y además se perfila
como un precandidato presidencial
también republicano para las elecciones
del 2024 por el lado demócrata el gran
ganador sin duda es el presidente Joe
biden quien pues se veía estas
elecciones como un referendo a su
mandato y los demócratas han salido
votar en masa y han apoyado el el lema
de campaña de las banderas de de los
demócratas que ha sido del aborto y la
defensa de la Democracia sin embargo en
el partido demócrata los perdedores son
congresistas del estado de Nueva York
que están perdiendo escaños y que
podrían asegurar en los próximos días
entonces la mayoría republicana en la
cámara baja